hey everyone welcome to this video by
simply learn in this session we'll be
comparing the three cutting-edge Y
development technologies that is
react.js angular and view we learn about
the key differences that make them so
distinct all of these technology stacks
have been replacing pure server-side
technologies and we've slowly progressed
from server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and a
part on the server side and now we'll
transition to something on a single page
applications or s.p.a and all of these
technologies that you see on your screen
right now are based purely on JavaScript
as a result they're lightweight and
aren't dependent on any third party
runtime tools so let's compare the three
technologies and learn about the factors
that make them stand out so let's see
what's in it for you we learn about
their features use cases and where
they're applied the performance how they
handle data the languages they use and
the testing mechanisms we learn about
the dedicated user community that backs
these technologies and finally we will
see the growth curve first we'll look
into the salient features now react is a
front-end JavaScript library while
angular and view are JavaScript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably this is significantly
different now lab DG is a set of classes
or functions and the user is in complete
control to call them free muffs on the
other hand elect models they have
limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on reactors used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on CSS HTML javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component perform
the specific tasks say for example one
component handles the login the other
one would display icons and images and
so on all these bits or components are
then put together to form a single page
application and moving on react was
developed and maintained by Facebook
while angular was built by Google and
view was developed by Avenue and X
Google employee now react represents the
view part of the MVC framework and
angular is a full-fledged MVC framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the MVC framework now what exactly is
then we see framework MVC framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while view deals with the representation
and the UI logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
Facebook Instagram Netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by Nike HBO Forbes Sony and
view is commonly used by alibaba.com
gramley 9gag and adobe moving on we have
performance and performance is a very
crucial feature now the moment you build
an HTML view and render it into the
browser this view to the user is
basically just HTML tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balance tree
structure this b-tree algorithm is
extremely fast so when the user makes
any changes to the UI the changes are
reflected immediately this is
facilitated by the b-tree algorithm so
as a result the performance is improved
so how does react make use of this tool
it uses a virtual Dom Dom is an API
developed by w3c it stands for document
object model and defines how the
document is accessed and manipulated
this Dom parser converts the HTML code
into an inverse balance tree structure
so DIAC uses the virtual Dom where
angular uses the real
and view uses the virtual Dom again now
the virtual Dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
HTML pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real Dom updation
is time-consuming risky and error-prone
view also ensures faster and bug free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider
the scenario where you log in to an
e-commerce website as a user one then
you should be able to see the items in
your shopping cart while user two would
be seeing different items in their
shopping carts and so on so identifying
the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one-way data-binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa and Valona on the other hand uses
a two-way data-binding
well view also uses a similar to v data
binding in react every time the model
state updates the view changes
accordingly however the reverse is not
true in case of angular any changes made
to the view are immediately reflected in
the model part of the architecture view
follows the same principle now this
hugely influences the performance due to
1 beta binding reactors modular and fast
improving the performance angular's
two-way data binding adversely effects
the performance and view on the other
hands performs according to the input
type moving on to scripting languages
react combines UI templates and
JavaScript logic resulting in a new
language called JSX so react only
requires a knowledge of JavaScript
angular uses templates again in HTML you
can also inject JavaScript code into
HTML using the clever implementation and
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
HTML angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
app
occasion using the newer language
developed by Microsoft called
typescript it is a compiled language and
is very similar to Java and c-sharp in
terms of syntax now view again uses HTML
base template it uses html5 throughout
for the UI and the combination of
javascript for business logic all view
templates are valid HTML and can be
passed by HTML parsers let's move on to
testing now just as the framework or an
API that is developed by Facebook and is
used to run tests on react applications
to ensure that they are bug free now it
is embedded typically in every react
labadie and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
Jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is
error-free
the view CLI or the command-line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of just or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open-source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js dot
org and so on you can raise queries
solve a few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third-party plugins
and also explore these tags even deeper
all of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing there
were about 1 million repositories 5
million commits and 1 million issues
with respect to the Act here are the
figures for angular and here are the
figures for view according to npm stat
over the past two years there have been
approximately 360 million react.js
downloads there have been around 38
million downloads for angular and around
63 million downloads for view now let's
look at the future scope learning a new
technology always comes with questions
like what's in it for me
what's its growth potential how far will
it take me in my career and so on so
let's go ahead and see the growth rate
of react angular and view according to
google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angle
view which have considerably lost their
momentum now this indicates that
reactors growing faster than the other
two with respect to popularity industry
adoption and community support so with
that we conclude this session with
ruining keywords like single page
applications JavaScript component based
design Model View controller and a whole
lot of other things so I hope this video
really helped you gain clarity about
these technologies thank you so much for
being here keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here